Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
I make fitness fun!
We're getting lit.
Do you see this?
I've grown this
to $1.4 million in sales.
Oh!
I started my business so I could
be in control of my destiny.
I'm ready
to take over the world.
That ain't bad.
I really want to save you
from this character.
You wouldn't like him.
Yikes!
You're just making noise.
Talk is cheap.
Greiner: Oh, my gosh.
John:
Wait a minute.
Now that I saw Barbara
all over this
like a truffle pig
on a truffle...
He doesn't know a damn thing
about the franchise business.
So?!
And he's a guy.
Oh, my God.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a business
centered around
a Southern specialty.
♪♪
Hi, y'all.
My name is Holly Cooper,
owner of Fried Green Tomatoes,
from Nashville, Tennessee,
and I am seeking $200,000
in exchange for 15% equity
of my company,
Fried Green Tomatoes.
Our food truck makes every item
fresh to order,
and our bacon, lettuce,
fried green tomato sandwich
is the favorite.
John: Mmm!
Mmm!
Other favorites are
our grouper sandwich,
a shrimp po'boy.
Mmm!
We have a catfish sandwich.
Oh, yeah.
But we're known best by visitors
from all over the country
for our hand‐battered
fried green tomatoes,
fried pickles,
and our secret sauce.
[ Slurping ]
[ Laughter ]
Our products are flying off
the shelves in retail stores.
So, Sharks, this business
is ripe with opportunities.
So who'd like to help spread
a little bit
of Nashville's
Southern hospitality
all over the country?
Are y'all hungry?
Greiner: We are!
We're hungry.
Corcoran: Let's go.
Yay! Great job.
Cuban:
Good job, Holly.
Thank you.
Now feed us.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Alright.
Thank you.
This is from
our food truck.
Beautiful.
Thank you, Holly.
Thank you.
Here you are,
babe.
Thank you, Holly.
Thank you.
Corcoran: I don't know
if I'll get my mouth around it.
O'Leary: Thank you.
Here you are, sir.
Thank you.
Mmm!
Alright.
Whoa!
That's very good,
Holly.
This is great!
Cooper: Thank you!
This is the best part of the job
and the worst part of the job.
Yeah, this is great.
So, we do a seasonal business
of special events.
However,
I just purchased a truck
that we're gonna be taking out
for more lunch events.
Our food truck is actually
a 16‐foot trailer.
Most of our events,
we're doing $600 to $800
an hour in business.
Greiner: Wow!
John: Wow. Really?
Wow.
And we have customers
waiting...
So good.
...more than an hour
to get their favorites.
Really?
Wow!
Yes.
O'Leary: Holly, it's fantastic.
I love it.
The fried green tomato thing,
I just inhaled.
Mmm!
But there's so many
food trucks.
I mean,
what's the deal?
Well, actually,
it's more than a food truck.
We have a product that we sell
to retailers nationwide.
Which is
this batter mix?
Is that
what this thing is?
Cooper: Right.
We took that product to market
in 2016.
We sold in 42 states,
about 600 stores.
600?
More boutique stores.
And we'd like to get into
more of the big‐box stores.
The batters cost me $1.28.
O'Leary: Yeah?
They retail for $8.99.
Cuban:
What are your sales?
We did $268,000 last year.
Good for you.
So, it's all of your sales
collectively?
Right.
So, Holly,
tell us about you.
I was in the restaurant business
for about 18 years.
I actually owned a small café
and actually sold that business,
and then
I got into commercial sales.
For what kind of
commercial sales?
I've sold fuel ‐‐
commercial fuel.
I've also sold plumbing,
HVAC business,
electrical business.
[ Laughs ]
Awesome.
Wow.
So you can sell
anything.
You name it, honey,
I can sell it.
Why did you leave sales to
go back into the food business?
Oh, actually, I lost my job.
Oh.
I lost my job.
I was the number 1 sales rep
for the company,
I was number 3
in the nation...
Wow.
...and I had just sold
a state contract,
and they let me go.
So that's why I started
my business ‐‐
so I could be in control
of my destiny.
Good for you.
Well, I'm gonna tell you
why they fired you.
They were jealous
of your talent.
I think so.
But the beauty is, is you can,
at any point in time,
take your life and your destiny
into your own hands
and you can create
a business or product,
and that's freedom,
and that's success.
Yes.
What is
your aspiration?
I would love to be able
to franchise our food truck.
You want to franchise?
And I have had more than a dozen
people want to buy a franchise,
and I just don't really know
how to do that,
so I'd love some help.
Not to be negative,
but, you know,
I have to speak the truth ‐‐
I am Mr. Wonderful.
$200,000 for 15%
means you value the business
for $1.3 million.
To pay $1.3 million for
this business is very difficult.
If you had
an already established
series of franchisees
that were making money,
that makes it
more believable
that you could pour gasoline
on the fire and make it bigger.
Right.
But you don't
have that yet.
Look, I think
the food's fantastic.
Good!
But it's just too small.
It's not investable.
I'm out.
I understand.
Like I said,
I've had restaurants,
and I've done more dollars
out of a food truck
than I've done in a café.
What you've done
is really quite amazing,
and I'm sure you're having
a whole lot more fun...
I am.
...working for yourself.
That's exactly right.
I loved what I ate,
but I'm that person
that goes for the healthy,
the light, the low‐fat,
so the product's not right
for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you. Thank you.
John: Holly,
you have $268,000 in sales,
and that is a combination
of the truck
as well as the product
in retailers.
Yes.
I actually just brought
my daughter on full time.
Sure.
So with the two of us,
we can definitely
more than double those numbers
this year.
It's nice that
you brought in your daughter,
but in order
to really take an investment
and accelerate
the growth...
Yes.
...you have to get
that point where,
"Okay, how can I get to
five employees?
How can I get
to 10 employees?"
Right.
And that's something,
really,
that an entrepreneur
has to go through.
I just don't think
you're investable yet,
so for those reasons, I'm out,
but congratulations.
I remember when
the Cousins Maine Lobster boys
came in here,
the two cousins...
Yes.
...the most important question
they answered was,
"How much
are you doing a day?"
And they had only been
in business three months.
Yes.
And they said,
"$5,000 a day."
We've done $6,400 a day,
has been our top.
So that's more than
$3 million a year
if you had your trucks open
six or seven days a week.
Right.
All of a sudden,
Barb can do math.
Cooper: Yes.
Well, this kind of math,
I can do
because I know it
inside and out.
You obviously can sell
like crazy.
I can.
Well, I am
your dream partner.
Okay, but I'm gonna
have to be very well‐paid
because I can do
so much for you
and I can make you rich
within two years ‐‐
no doubt in my mind.
Oh, my Lord.
Let me tell you something.
You can make an empire
of franchises out of this.
But the important ingredients
that those two cousins have is,
boy, can they sell
Yeah.
and, boy,
are they organized.
Yes.
As a result of that,
they have $60 million in sales
three years later.
I know. I want to be them!
[ Laughs ]
You will be them.
No doubt in my mind
you will be them.
So, I'll offer you the $200,000
for 30% of your business.
Cuban:
That's a no‐brainer.
No, think about it.
It really is.
Wait a minute!
Now that I saw Barbara
all over this
like a truffle pig
on a truffle...
[ Laughs ]
...I'll give you
$200,000 for 25%.
And he doesn't know a damn thing
about the franchise business.
So?!
Stay here. Stay here.
Corcoran:
And he's a guy.
I love you.
I really do.
Greiner:
What are you gonna do?
You save 5%
on the Daymond discount.
Yeah.
♪♪
Barbara,
could we get to 25%?
I'm worth it.
I know you've got
the experience.
She's worth it.
I'm worth it.
I'm a genius at this.
I really ‐‐
I really love you guys.
I love all of you.
Um...
♪♪
I think
I'm gonna take Barb's.
Whoa!
You're a smart woman.
Congratulations.
I'm sorry.
O'Leary: She paid more!
I'm sorry. I love ‐‐
I'm sorry.
We got rid
of that guy.
I know! I know!
You're so smart.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you, doll!
Thank you.
Too bad, Daymond.
Ha ha ha!
In the fried‐food business,
never trust a skinny person.
I know! I know!
I know.
I'm your guy!
Congratulations. I would've
never thought you'd get a deal.
Thank you!
And you did!
Congratulations, Holly.
Thank you. [ Laughs ]
Corcoran: It was like
taking candy from a baby.
Why didn't you guys want
that business? It's a gold mine.
You never know what's gonna
happen on "Shark Tank."
It was worth giving up a little
more equity to get Barbara
because I knew that she had the
experience to do what we needed,
and she's the Shark I was after,
and so we're thrilled
to have her as a partner.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a handy tool
for gardening lovers.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Mollie Thorsen,
and this is my dad.
I'm Bob Thorsen.
And we're the Little Burros!
[ Laughter ]
We're here today
seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
♪♪
Sharks, my wife loves to work
in the garden,
but she keeps
losing her tools,
and she'll say,
"Bob, where's my cellphone?
Where's my rake?
Where's my iced tea?"
[ Laughter ]
And I wanted
my mornings back,
so I decided
to do something about it.
So that's why Dad created
the Burro Buddy,
a garden tray
that sits right on top
of your standard‐size
wheelbarrows,
maximizing organization
while minimizing your trips
running back and forth.
The Burro Buddy can hold
your long‐handled tools,
your short‐handled tools,
your drink,
and even has
a water‐resistant compartment
to protect your cellphone
from the elements
or from Dad's
garden‐hose sprays.
And at 3 pounds,
it's lightweight
and it comes
right on and right off.
So you can use it
as a garden tray
as you move
around the yard.
Just don't forget
where you leave it.
[ Chuckling ]
Yes, Dad.
As you can see,
the Little Burros
is a family‐owned business,
and we're made right here
in the USA.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to make big money
with the Little Burros?
[ Chuckles ]
Cuban: That's great.
Bob, what led you to become
wheelbarrow experts?
Tell us about
this incredible journey.
Alright.
I'm a general contractor
in Washington, D. C.
I would've bet
you were a basketball coach.
You got the sweater,
you got the demeanor.
Greiner: Yeah.
Even the way
you hold your hands.
I have three sons
who played basketball.
They were on
award‐winning teams,
and so
I'm used to that, but ‐‐
I played basketball, too.
And you played.
And your daughter,
right?
Wow!
Bob!
I did, too.
[ Laughs ]
What's your background?
My background ‐‐
I actually graduated
with an art‐history degree,
but growing up,
I was one of five kids,
and watching Dad
and the business,
I just love
the family business.
So, my three brothers
are involved
in the construction company,
and when I graduated,
Dad thought of this genius idea,
and he said,
"What do you think?
Do you think we can make it
and sell it?"
And I was like, "Yes."
So, my sister, Rebecca,
was our CFO,
[ Voice breaking ]
and she passed away in 2016.
Aw.
Oh, I'm sorry.
We kind of
have been making sure
that we do our part
to continue her legacy
because she helped us with
every single part of this.
So this is your baby.
It's my baby.
So why don't you tell us about
the sales, who's buying it?
Yeah.
Yeah, so, we are in
big‐box retailers nationwide,
and we do about 2,500 a month
since January.
$25 a month?
Wow.
2,500 units a month.
Wow!
2,500 units?
That's great!
Which equates
to how much money?
Since January 1st,
we have done close to $400,000.
Wow!
Very good.
Where are you?
What retailers are you in?
Right now, we are in
Target stores nationwide.
Target.
Yes.
And we are in Menards
nationwide...
Menards.
...we're in Duluth Trading,
we're in Ace stores nationwide,
True Value stores nationwide.
And what is
the cost of one?
Packaged
and all put together,
$10.50 is
what we make it for.
We sell it $25 FOB
and $39.95 MSRP.
And we are made
in the United States.
Wait. I'm sorry.
Freight on board.
FOB to me is
"first on the boat."
So freight on board.
Yes.
Okay.
$10 ‐‐
So we sell at $25,
and they pay
for all the shipping.
But what would you
use the money for? I don't
see you need the money.
Well,
you want $250,000.
For what?
What would you
use it for?
Well, we actually
want to build
a quality,
innovative tool‐brand line.
We want to continue with this
and build more products.
All in
the gardening theme?
Yeah, we have more innovative
ideas we'd like to do,
and I would not like to keep
using Thorsen money to do it.
[ Laughter ]
Bob, how much of your own money
have you put into the business?
We've put
about a million dollars.
Ohhhhh!
John: Ohhhh!
O'Leary:
Yippee‐yi‐yo‐ki‐yay!
Greiner: Wow!
No wonder you don't want
to put any more!
Somebody's grandkids
aren't going to college.
Bob: And by the way,
you all didn't ask ‐‐
everything's patented.
Oh, it is?
Whoa.
This is utility patent,
design patent.
Utility patent?
That's what cost you
the million dollars.
Mollie: Yeah.
So, just within the design
and engineering
and the injection mold,
that's roughly
half a million dollars alone.
That's what gave you
the gray hair, right, Bob?
When I first made
my first product,
I spent $275,000
on molds.
Right.
And it's a huge risk
to take.
Mollie, you certainly know
your numbers. I like that.
Corcoran:
I'm an avid gardener.
I'm having a hard time,
though,
because I've been gardening
my whole life,
but I never even thought to buy
a wheelbarrow, honest to God.
What I do is,
I just take a bucket
and I fill it with soil, and I
jam all my instruments in it,
and I carry it around.
So, I think your sales
are remarkable,
but, for me,
I just can't imagine using it,
and therefore, I can't really
relate to it myself.
And so, for that reason only,
I'm out.
Thank you.
The next gardening I do will be
the first gardening I do.
I mean, I wouldn't know
where to begin with this.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
I got to tell you, I like
everything about this story.
I love the fact that you're able
to work with your family.
I just don't know anything
about this business.
I mean, there's one person
up here that,
if it's under $50
and it's plastic...
It's Kevin!
...she's gonna sell it.
She sells more plastic
than Happy Meals here.
I sell a lot of stuff to
hardware stores, so I'm
pretty familiar with it.
Listen, I just can't help you
with this business,
but I'm really excited
about it. I love this.
Well, thank you.
I'm struggling with it,
but I'm out.
We appreciate you.
Bob, you're the inventor ‐‐
very credible, no question ‐‐
and, Mollie,
you're running it.
So who actually owns
Little Burros?
Bob: The family.
My wife
owns the biggest share.
That's usually the way
things work out, Bob.
[ Laughs ]
The problem is,
you bring an outside investor
who's not a family member,
it kind of reminds me
of my problems with
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
There's 26 family members that
own a piece of this thing now,
and it's a challenge.
The way I got around the problem
was a royalty deal
because I don't own any equity
but I get paid.
Royalty?!
And so, look,
I don't know.
I mean, it kind of fits into
my hardware business.
It's got
the same exact buyers.
What hardware
business?
What hardware business,
Kevin?
I have a huge business now
in hardware with BenjiLock.
I am the lock.
Oh, okay.
Oh! One product.
Yeah, but it's the biggest
lock product you've ever seen.
But he is one
with the lock.
The deal I would offer you ‐‐
I'll make you an offer.
I'll do the $250,000.
I want a royalty
of 10 bucks a unit.
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran:
They're laughing at you.
You gonna let me
get the offer out?
Doesn't matter!
Look at Mollie.
She's laughing.
It doesn't work well
because that's about ‐‐
O'Leary: Would you rather
not get an offer?
They only make
a little bit more than that.
Well, it's the same cost
as the cost of the unit.
Yeah, we'd love to hear
your offer.
We're still listening.
We're still here.
Yeah, we're listening.
O'Leary: I mean...
We're listening.
If you're not loving
the offer already ‐‐
We're entertained by this
all day, every day.
I'm telling you, look,
the great thing about ‐‐
But, Kevin,
that's almost half the cost
they're paying for the goods.
I don't think you're writing
a check, are you? I forgot.
They sell it for $25,
make it for $10.50...
I'm not.
...give Kevin $10
of the $15 left.
You know, talk is cheap, Mollie.
You know that.
Well, I'm glad you guys
got a wheelbarrow.
An offer is an offer.
Here you go.
And here's my offer.
$250,000 against a $7 royalty
till I get back $500,000,
and I'm only gonna take 7%
of the equity in the company.
Oh, my God. Bob.
Corcoran: What a nice guy.
Greiner: Oh, my gosh!
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful.
Well, Lori,
let's hear your offer.
Well, you know,
I've got a problem here.
I'm not sure
that the average home
with a garden in a backyard
has a wheelbarrow.
We think that our Burro Buddy
would do great on QVC.
I'm not sure it's a TV item,
'cause it's seasonal,
so it's only gonna sell
in the summer.
I'm really torn here.
What are you gonna do,
Lori?
The $1 million in?
Whoa.
I mean, I'm like,
"How do I get anything out?"
It's a flier here.
You've only been selling
since January.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
You might not like the offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Bob and Mollie have one offer
on the table from Kevin
and one on the way from Lori
for their gardening‐tool
company, the Little Burros.
It's a flier here.
You've only been selling
since January.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
You might not like the offer.
♪♪
I'm gonna give you the $250,000
as a loan.
I'm gonna want $5 back
until I get my loan back.
And I only want
3% of the company.
♪♪
Both greedy offers.
Are you gonna make an offer,
Barbara?
No.
I would be insulted
with those offers.
It's risky.
It's super, super,
super risky.
So, then,
you're just making noise.
Talk is cheap.
Offers are real.
Because you have
a million dollars
that you're gonna want
to pay yourself back.
But are you giving a loan
at interest, or you're giving...
My interest is at 6%.
John: Ohh.
O'Leary: That's debt.
That's debt.
Ouch.
Mollie: Yeah.
It's debt, but, listen,
I'm gonna be a Little Burro.
When does the loan go away?
I get $5 royalty
till I get the loan back.
Okay.
Okay?
And then I just get 3%.
So you're getting me
grinding, burrowing.
Yeah.
But you're paying interest
and royalties.
Yeah. Yes.
Yeah, so you have two similar
bloodsucking offers here.
But if you are
making millions...
Lori, just to be clear ‐‐
Corcoran: May I give you
some unbiased advice?
Barbara.
Nothing in it
for me.
Barbara, hang on.
No.
Could you be quiet
just for a minute?
John:
That's not gonna happen.
No, I want to give them advice
to walk away from both deals,
and I'll tell you why.
You already put
your million dollars in.
You already did
the heavy lifting.
You're already getting traction
within the stores.
It's like you climb
this huge hill, a painful hill,
and you came over the top,
and it's getting easy,
and then you're gonna let
these guys run up to you
and take a big bite
out of your butt.
Barbara always says that when
she's not interested in a deal.
Says Barbara,
who has no money in the deal,
not taking any risks,
just talking.
I'm not vested in it. I'm giving
you my honest opinion.
But she's right.
Talk is cheap.
Greiner: You guys know
what you want.
And listen.
There's a reason why
we're similar sitting here.
You just started
in January.
Corcoran: They're feeding off
each other's greed.
We don't know
what's gonna happen.
And, you know...
there's a lot going on here.
There's a fair amount of work
to promote this.
There's a lot
going on here.
What do you want to do?
John: What do you want to do?
I think that,
looking at this,
like, royalty isn't what
our original offer had involved,
so I don't know
that a royalty deal
is something
that we would look at.
But if you guys
were interested in equity,
we'd still really be interested
in working with you guys.
My deal is gonna stay
a royalty deal.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
And, Mollie, I don't have
any flexibility, either,
'cause I'm just
commensurate with the risk.
I look at it ‐‐ you know, we've
done 10 years of "Shark Tank."
We've done
every kind of deal.
And we're getting very
good at understanding
our risks and rewards.
He's amazing ‐‐
just amazing.
Yes.
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful, Barbara.
[ Laughs ]
So, all you've got
are those two offers, Bob,
and I think
they're pretty good.
You have to choose between
the two of them. Mollie
understands the numbers.
Cuban:
You don't have to choose.
Or choose nothing at all.
It's your call, Dad.
♪♪
We cannot do
a royalty deal.
Phew! Good for you.
Thank you guys
so much, though.
Greiner: It's okay.
We really appreciate it.
Listen, I wish you good luck
no matter what.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I know
you will do great.
Thank you.
Great decision, guys.
Congrats, guys.
Thanks.
Ah, thank God.
Mollie:
I know my sister, Becca,
would be, like, really,
really proud of us
because we made
a smart decision
at the end of the day.
Yes. Yeah.
And that's
the most important thing,
is making
the smart decision.
Yes.
So...
Narrator: Earlier this season,
"Shark Tank" announced
a special sweepstakes
for high school students.
Four winners won
a personal video chat
with their favorite Shark,
and the Sharks
had a special surprise
for the grand‐prize winner,
Connelly.
Herjavec: Hey, guys!
Did you all know that Connelly
won the sweepstakes?
Yeah, Connelly!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Connelly:
I've been watching "Shark Tank"
for as long as I can remember.
Every Sunday night,
me and my friends watch
"Shark Tank" together.
We love it.
It's such a fun show.
In the future, I would love
to start my own business,
so this is definitely
one of the coolest things
that's ever happened to me.
Connelly,
come with us.
Cuban:
By winning the sweepstakes,
Connelly and her family
are gonna be able to come out
and visit us on set,
but that wasn't enough
for the Sharks.
We wanted to come out here
to Chattanooga, Tennessee,
and surprise
the entire school.
Let's give
a big Charger welcome
to the Sharks
from "Shark Tank."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cuban: We're here to inspire
the entrepreneurs of tomorrow.
We also invited one of my
Shark Tank companies, Zoobean,
and Junior Library Guild
to come out and join us.
We're donating $10,000
of brand‐new books.
Bookey:
We're giving every student
access to
our Beanstack software.
We want to get them fired up
about starting
their own businesses
and being the next generation
of Sharks.
Who are the people who inspired
you to be entrepreneurs?
What are some of the sacrifices
an entrepreneur must make?
How would you advise us
as teenagers to get started?
How many people here
are on TikTok?
Alright,
that's an opportunity.
Go into a business that
you think is doing
business the old way,
and you show them
how to activate social media.
Greiner: Most people out there
that have several years on you
are gonna need your help.
O'Leary:
We need more young people
to be entrepreneurs
because they're the next
generation of problem‐solvers.
They see the world
in a whole new light.
Connelly posts a tweet,
and the five of us
show up today.
The impossible can happen.
[ Applause ]
Herjavec: All it takes
is one great idea.
There's one kid sitting out
there in a high school somewhere
that's gonna change the world.
Great job, Connelly.
I really appreciate
you all coming.
Well done.
Thank you.
Connelly:
This day has been incredible.
To be able to meet the Sharks
has just been
an absolute dream come true.
[ Audience chanting
"Shark Tank" ]
Greiner: The message we want
to send to these kids today is,
whatever they dream of,
whatever they want to be,
they can be entrepreneurs,
they can be successful,
and they are our future.
[ Audience cheering ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
a way to get fit and have fun.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is LaDonte Lotts.
"Mr. Get Right"
is what they call me.
And I am the owner and founder
of JiggAerobics,
where we get lit
while we get fit.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, look,
today I'm seeking $50,000
for a 12% equity in my company.
Now, you sitting there
looking ‐‐
"What is JiggAerobics?"
Let me tell you.
JiggAerobics started off
as an on‐campus initiative
to get students more involved
into health and wellness.
Being on a college campus,
I noticed that we do not like
to work out,
we don't like to walk,
we don't like to move ‐‐
unless we're dancing
at a party, right?
I made JiggAerobics fun.
I make fitness fun!
We're working out.
We're getting lit.
Do you see this?
Jiggin'.
[ Laughs ]
Jiggin' was a dance style
that started off
in Baton Rouge, Louisiana,
alright?
You're moving your legs
at a very fast pace.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
You're moving your arms.
You see these shoulders?
It's a whole‐body movement,
and we're having fun.
You're not thinking about
the workout,
but afterward,
you'll be dripping in sweat.
Now, Sharks,
before we get down to business,
before we get down to it,
I want you to come get jiggy
with me, okay?
Do you want
to get jiggy with me?
to get jiggy with me? No?
Corcoran: Yeah, sure.
Let's go.
Come on, come on!
I will.
Greiner:
Barb, you go ahead.
Come on, now!
Get jiggy.
Ah, yeah. Let me help you down.
Yes, ma'am.
Thank you so much.
How's it going?
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you. So true.
Mr. Get Right is here
to get you right, okay?
Okay.
Now, we're gonna start
with the left foot, alright?
Left leg, we're gonna go
1, 2, 3, 4.
What number do I clap on?
Sharks: 4.
[ Laughs ]
Now, look, once you clap,
you're gonna freestyle, okay?
I want to see your freestyle.
Yeah, there you go!
Now I want to see
your money, baby.
Money, baby.
Yeah, yeah!
Sure.
I want to see you freestyle,
alright?
So, let's start
with the left leg.
Here we go.
Let's get the music.
[ Hip‐hop music plays ]
You ready?
Yeah.
You sure?
Come on,
we got this, a'ight?
Here we go.
We got 'em.
Let's go.
Freestyle!
Yeah.
You better freestyle!
Right leg. Right leg.
You got it. Right.
Come on,
Ms. Barbara, yeah.
Ooh! You better get it!
You better get it!
You better...
Yeah!
Let's go.
How fun!
There you go! There you go!
Give me some. Give me some.
Good job, good job, good job.
Good job.
It wasn't that good.
[ Laughs ]
LaDonte, how do I
make any money with this?
What's the plan?
We're utilizing
the Louisiana dance style
and mixing it with aerobics,
so it's different fitness,
it's lit, it's fun.
So I pay you
for a class?
Yes, sir, a class ‐‐
an hour class.
So, our prices
are $15 per person,
$10 per person
after 50 people.
Cuban: Where are you doing it
right now?
Right now I'm just traveling
to different states,
different regions
to expand the brand.
I do a pop‐up class,
I talk to CrossFit gyms,
and we just launched
our online subscription site.
This is the stretching
and warm‐up.
Once you sign up, you get the
stretching and warm‐up for free,
so that way, you could get
accommodated with the style.
So, you know, you get to
experience not only, you know,
face‐to‐face,
but you get it at home, as well.
Okay,
you own the trademark to it?
Yeah, trademarked.
Yes, sir.
Tell us about you.
Alright.
Growing up, I always danced,
and I was trained
for all styles,
but, you know, being in
a single‐parent home,
we weren't able
to afford it.
So I would go to YouTube,
I would go to watch
Michael Jackson old videos,
so that way, I can make sure
I'm always polished
with my dance moves, you know?
[ Laughter ]
So, once I went to college ‐‐
to Southern University
in Baton Rouge, Louisiana ‐‐
I don't know if you know
about Louisiana,
but their culture is very,
very strong.
And once I got involved
with the marching band,
they appointed me
as the choreographer
for the field shows,
and I had to learn
the style of dance.
I didn't know anything about
Louisiana style of dance.
And when I seen
the jiggin' dance,
they were moving so fast.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
And when it was finished,
they were drenching in sweat.
I said, "That's not a dance ‐‐
that's a workout."
LaDonte,
you put on one class...
Yes, ma'am.
...you teach the other trainers
how to do it,
and then you leave
to another city?
No, see,
right now I'm getting ready
to start certifying trainers.
That's what the $50,000 is
for ‐‐ is to certify trainers.
And they pay you a fee
to be trained?
They pay a one‐time fee
for the certification,
and then you would pay
a monthly subscription base.
Okay, so,
what are the revenues?
Right now we had a total
of $62,000 for the year.
We only been operating
as a business for a year.
For the year?
Oh, good for you.
Yes, sir.
'Cause you want to make this
like a Zumba, correct?
Bigger than Zumba.
Ah, I see.
So you want to train people
in JiggAerobics?
But the model
is like it?
You got it.
Cuban: What year did
you graduate from Southern?
I graduated this past fall.
Oh, so you just
got out of school, huh?
I'm fresh, yes, sir.
You're fresh, okay.
Yes, sir. And now
I'm full‐time JiggAerobics.
That's great.
I mean, look...
Ready to go worldwide.
...right out of school,
$62K?
Yes.
That ain't bad.
Thank you.
There's nothing wrong
with the model you've got.
I mean,
other people have done it.
But how does an investor
play into this?
Well, I'm looking for
a strategic partner.
More than the money,
I'm looking for a strategic
partner to show me the route,
how they'll be able
to capitalize off of this
in the most powerful way.
I'm an entertainer, not just a
JiggAerobics fitness instructor.
JiggAerobics could be used
for performances.
We've performed at
basketball games, at concerts.
We do it all.
Yeah.
I mean, it's a
personal‐services business.
Nothing wrong with it.
I think it can grow.
You just need to leverage it up
and do four times more.
Right.
And you'll be making
100 grand a year.
Yes, sir.
It's just ‐‐ look,
I wish you the best.
I don't know how to put $50,000
into this or what it's worth.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
No problem.
I kind of am sitting here
thinking the same thing.
I feel like what you're really
doing and selling is you.
You entertain people.
That's why they want
to go to your class.
You're right.
So you're trying
to capitalize
on who you are
and this style of dance,
and I'm not really quite sure,
like, how to do that.
It's kind of early.
I think
you'll get there.
Yes, ma'am.
But as an investment
for me,
I'm just not sure
how I would invest in this.
So I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you. Thank you.
John: So, my train of thought
is that
I've been down this road
several times,
one with
Billy Blanks Jr.
and then another one with
my buddy/partner "Cowboy Ryan."
Rodeo Abs.
But it took a while
for them to figure out
the lane
that works best for them.
I just think you're a little
too early, so I'm out.
Thank you.
Corcoran: You know,
I think you were thinking
you could
get an investor in here
and your business
would speed forward.
The truth of the matter is,
it would slow you down
because the only person that
could hit the bumps in the road
and figure out
"Let's try this.
Oh, that doesn't work.
Let's try this"
is the guy
who's heading the business.
You have
so much more runway
before you would ever
need the help of anyone.
I'm looking for a strategic
partner, someone that could ‐‐
But a strategic partner
would do what?
Put you in the right place
at the right time?
There's only one way
to get to the right place
at the right time ‐‐
is to bumble along
until you discover
every little piece of it
on your own as an entrepreneur.
That's how everybody
grows their business.
So have a little more faith
in yourself.
I'd love to invest in you. I'm
sure you're gonna be a winner.
You know,
you just have that about you.
But there's no room
in this deal for me,
so, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Thank you.
LaDonte, your product
isn't JiggAerobics.
Your product's you,
right?
You're an entertainer.
Anybody could do a routine,
put something to music,
but you go there
and entertain, right?
Yes, sir.
And I see that.
It's not
that you need advice, right?
You just need to do
things like this and keep
on building your brand,
because the bigger your brand,
the bigger your personality,
the more events you're gonna do,
the more events you do,
the more you can charge,
the more money you'll make.
But just keep on doing
what you're doing online
and just keep on
getting bigger
and just have fun
like you're doing, man,
and then it'll take off.
You're out of school, man.
You're doing it exactly right.
I'm ready
to take over the world.
I feel like this product
is phenomenal.
Corcoran:
We believe you.
Give it another two or
three years, you'll be there.
We'll say, "Yeah,
we saw him on 'Shark Tank.'"
[ Corcoran laughs ]
So I can't invest, man,
but I'm excited for you.
I'll be watching.
I'll be watching your videos.
Maybe I'll even be
a subscriber.
But I'm out.
Thank you, Mr. Cuban.
Good luck, LaDonte.
Thank you.
Greiner: Good luck.
I'm feeling great.
The feedback
that I received from the Sharks
made me feel wonderful,
and they told me to go for it,
I don't need any help.
It boosted my confidence,
and I'm so ready to go
and take on the world.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a business
joining art and commerce.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm from
Bayside, Queens, New York.
And I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange for 15%
of my company, Mural Painter!
We specialize in ‐‐
you guessed it ‐‐
mural painting!
Oh.
And my name's Emily.
I put the "M"...
...in "mural painting"!
[ Laughter ]
Mural painting is one of
the most effective ways
to grab audiences' attention
and engage with...
the Millennials.
Picture this.
What if this gorgeous mural
was a promo
for "Shark Tank" season 11?
It would be
all over social media.
Check it out.
Hey, look at you, Daymond!
Mark, you're looking good!
Of course.
Kevin, watch out!
Save the money!
[ Laughter ]
Looking good, ladies.
Mural painting
and hand‐painted signage
was considered a lost art
not too long ago.
Now it's more desirable
than any other form of
semipermanent media out there.
On the flip side,
Mural Painter creates jobs
for artists
where they can still
do what they love,
beautify neighborhoods,
and feed their families.
How cool is that?
We're ready to expand,
so we're developing an app
which allows artists
and customers
to be matched
throughout the U. S.
So, Sharks, who's ready to
paint the town green with me ‐‐
money‐green?!
[ Laughter ]
How did you come up
with this idea?
So, I was always an artist.
When I was 16, my parents,
who are freakin' awesome,
they let me paint all over
the kitchen cabinets, right?
So, my mom,
she worked from home,
so her clients would have to
walk through the kitchen,
and they all saw
the kitchen cabinets,
and they're like,
"Oh, my God! Who did this?"
So they started hiring me,
and their friends
started hiring me,
and then
it snowballed from there
into a word‐to‐mouth business
around my neighborhood.
And then, around 17,
I got really, really sick.
I got, like, a late‐stage case
of Lyme disease.
It was very, very severe.
So I couldn't walk.
I couldn't really hold
a paintbrush or do anything.
Wow.
And it ultimately ‐‐
I ended up having to drop out
of high school.
So, I survived Lyme.
I got better.
I ended up getting my GED.
I ended up taking
some college classes
at FIT, in fine arts,
and the mural industry
completely exploded.
So, to to keep up
with the demand,
I kind of had to fake it
till I made it.
There's some guys up here
still doing that.
[ Laughter ]
I had to turn to my college
fine‐art classmates and be like,
"Hey, you want to make
like 50 bucks this weekend
and help me with this mural?"
But then, eventually,
assistants turned into employees
and small jobs
turned into big jobs,
and before I knew it,
MP was born.
Do you have any examples
of your work that we can see?
Yeah.
So, maybe you recognize
Bantam Bagels.
You did that for us?
Yeah!
Well, we do a lot
of hand‐painted signage
in the
brick‐and‐mortar locations,
a lot of
hand‐painted advertisements,
as you can see
in the third example,
as well as faux finishing.
Corcoran: How do you find
and vet your artists?
So, actually, right now
we have an East Coast
and a West Coast branch
in New York, Los Angeles,
and Chicago.
Every time we want to launch
in a new city,
we do an artist call.
We vet them
very, very heavily.
O'Leary: So you're
an artist agency?
I would say we are run
like a construction company,
but for artists.
That's a great description.
[ Laughs ]
And so, are you taking
a commission or a ‐‐
No, they're hourly.
Give me an example.
Okay, I want to paint
that mural.
How much do you charge me
for that?
So, something like that, 8x8,
would be around $15,000.
O'Leary: $15,000?
$15,000?
How many days would it take
to do that?
About three days.
And what
are you paying them?
They start at $16 an hour.
Is it typically one artist
working on your 8x8?
Or how many?
Around two.
Two? Okay.
So if you're paying them
$15 an hour to start
and they're working
a 10‐hour day,
that's $150 times 2.
$300 a day
times 3 to 4 days?
Right.
$1,200,
and you're charging $15K?
And is all that margin,
or what other costs
are associated with that?
We try to estimate
when we do our bidding.
We try to keep it
at a 40% to 50% means.
So, in this calendar year,
what are your revenues gonna be?
We're projected to land
at $800,000.
Yeah?
What are you gonna make
on the $800,000?
About $100,000.
That's after
paying yourself, though.
I pay myself only around,
like, $23,000.
Corcoran:
How do you live on $23,000
Wow.
in a city like New York?
[ Laughs ]
Uh, it's interesting.
I did have to go through
the eating the bread sandwiches.
[ Laughs ]
I ended up leaving FIT
and lived on the couch
in the Bronx
in a really bad neighborhood.
[ Laughs ]
But you can now afford
to give yourself more than that.
I can afford
to live myself.
I live five blocks away
from the office
'cause I work 17 hours a day,
so I have no time to commute.
O'Leary:
You know, obviously,
there's nothing proprietary
about what you're doing.
Right.
But the margins
look good.
They're very good.
What do you need
the $300,000 for?
So, I have a three‐step plan
for that $300,000.
Step 1 ‐‐ I want to launch
in a few more cities, right?
And then any of the extra funds,
use for marketing,
as well as our
dispatching system that we have.
I want to make a customized one,
special for our needs.
Who else
are you competing with?
We have very,
very few competitors
that would take on
a $15,000 mural.
Our other competitors
that are in the media space,
they won't touch a job
under, like, $50K.
Cuban: Look, Emily,
it's a great business.
The challenge I have is just
scaling it to be big enough.
You know,
as an owner/operator,
you know, you could grow
to $2 million,
make hopefully $1 million
and put it in your pocket,
and that's great.
I just ‐‐ I'd have
a hard time seeing
how I could help you get
to $5‐, $10‐, $20 million.
So, as proud I am
and excited for you as I am,
for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you so much, Mark.
♪♪
It's tough for me.
[ Sighs ]
It's impressive.
I think the personal issue
that I have is, you know,
my highest turnover
has always been
my graphic‐and‐design
department
because artists
are just artists.
I love their talent.
I wish I could do that.
But it's a challenge with me
working with them.
I've been burned
so much.
This is not for me,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
♪♪
O'Leary:
It's an impressive story.
Like, you basically
dropped out of high school,
and now you've got
an $800,000 business.
It's an unusual deal,
Emily.
It's hot right now, though!
No, I know, I know.
Everybody wants a mural!
I mean, after you've seen me,
you're gonna be looking around
and be like,
"There's murals everywhere!"
You are so strong
and so resourceful.
Sometimes,
the strongest swords
are forged in
the hottest fires.
If you're thinking
of going out,
I will be, seriously, the
hardest worker you'll ever meet.
I understand the industry
more than anyone else,
backwards and forwards.
I've grown this
from the ground up.
from $12 an hour
to $1.4 million in sales
to date,
and that's only counted
at 2 1/2 years.
I'm on my game.
Like, I want to grow this
so much.
Alright, look,
you're a funky chicken, Emily.
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
It's a different
kind of deal.
Look, I'll do the $300,000
for...
♪♪
...35%.
[ Chuckles ]
Yikes. [ Laughs ]
O'Leary: Yeah.
You know,
I wish you'd asked for less.
I'm giving you $300,000 ‐‐
a lot of money.
I know how much it takes 'cause
I've launched in other cities,
so I want a realistic amount.
Yeah, I want
a realistic amount, too.
I want 35%.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Emily is seeking $300,000
for a 15% stake
in her advertising company,
Mural Painter.
Kevin has offered her $300,000
for 35% of her company.
I'm not sure about
this business.
I'm 100% sure about you.
I think that Kevin's offer
is a good offer ‐‐
a little aggressive.
I'd like
to beat him up for you
and get him to come down
in his percentage.
O'Leary:
What are you gonna do?
I'll circle back to that.
I'm spunky.
But I don't think
it's right for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Barbara,
if you need any clarification
in relation
to what Lori said...
Corcoran: I do.
...I'm more than happy to
kind of talk you through it.
I think the key to the business
is twofold.
One ‐‐ your artists.
You've got that covered.
The other piece
is the client relationship ‐‐
the big ad agencies,
the smaller agencies.
I think
there's so much more depth
in the client market
to sell to.
What disturbs me
is that you focused on
doing a small business again
somewhere else,
versus taking your roots
and making a big‐ass business
out of it.
Well, what would you
suggest, then?
Do we turn them down?
I would suggest
you not worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
And let me tell you why.
I remember
when I was building
my New York City‐based
brokerage firm.
I had a phenomenal client
who moved to Connecticut
with all their
corporate executives,
and I thought I was prudent
in following them out there
and opening a big office.
I lost my shirt.
But, more importantly,
my core business stopped growing
for almost two years because
of that stupid sidewinder.
I didn't realize the depth
of the New York City market
for me to build my business
by a hundredfold,
and that's
what I focused on.
I do want
to make you an offer
just so you don't get in bed
with this creepy guy.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause that would be
a mistake
'cause there's nothing
he could do for your business.
O'Leary: I ‐‐ I ‐‐
I'll give you the $100,000
of the $300,000 as cash.
Okay?
And I'll give you
a $200,000 line of credit.
That's the only way the numbers
actually make sense ‐‐
for 15%.
I was gonna ask 20%,
but I really want to save you
from this character, okay?
Really, I mean it.
You wouldn't like him
to do business with ‐‐ truly.
There's only one
Mr. Wonderful, Emily.
I'm sure.
I'm gonna stick with my offer.
I'm comfortable with it.
If I take your offer,
you're a partner of mine,
so I value everything
that you ‐‐
What do you see
for what happens next?
I think
what you have to do
is give more depth to
your sales line, which is you.
You're all over the place.
From what you said,
I think you're mostly
an administrator at this point.
What a waste
of your talent.
I completely agree.
So I can teach you
how to structure your business
where it makes optimal sense
of your talent, alright?
Would you suggest
a sales team?
I wouldn't say
a sales team, no.
I bet you most of your business
is coming to you,
versus you going out
for it.
Correct.
That means there's a lot
of business to be had.
Anybody who listens to you
is gonna fall in love with you.
I would've never guessed
you would've got two offers,
I got to tell you,
the beginning of the pitch...
So, what do you want to do?
♪♪
Barbara, you got a deal!
Yes!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ohh!
Thank you so much!
Cuban:
Well done. Well done.
Good for you.
You don't know
what this means!
What a great job you did.
We're gonna kill it!
I know that.
Alright.
Ciao. Love you.
Thank you so much.
Cuban: Congrats, Emily.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much, guys!
Well done.
Strauss:
I am so excited for the future.
I am so grateful
for this opportunity.
I've worked so hard for this.
I got a deal with exactly
who I came in for
at exactly my asking price ‐‐
just sliced up differently.
And my equity ‐‐
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪